now Walmart for Andre fetch up again in back
of the goal he stops in the dive lacrosse move
scores what a goal Andre's fettic off reaches
into those bag of tricks for some magic here
in the third period a highlight real goal he has
scored some Beauties in his young NHL career but
from a sheer fashion perspective well that beats
anybody signature moment for a guy overflowing
with confidence to try that knocking on the door
fetch the cof out of the corner and back of the
goal acros move he scores he did it again Andre
fetch the his second lacrosse style goal wow the
lacrosse move is now officially International he
did it against the Calgary Flames and Canadian
team at home but now it's cross Customs it
has gotten through immigration and a gigantic
goal face off loose for forsberg he's got some
open Ice lifts it up and tries to put it in and
does there's the goal he's been looking for full
speed behind the net lacrosse style upper corner
forsberg ties it Phillip forsberg oh my goodness
and he's going to flip it up right there right
in the top of the net and beats Mike Smith in
full motion welcome to the club Philip forsberg
oh my goodness Z behind the net he knows there he
goes right to him Zer here he can oh look at this
oh he it's in oh my goodness what a goal looks
like he's going for the old Michigan he brings
it up Miller goes to knock it off he shoots it
in front oh pass to Milano wow and he could see
SE too he grabs his head look at him he's like
I can't believe it actually worked I've never
seen anything like that speechless so a minute 15
in oh the lros try again are you kidding me he's
done it again Trevor zis what an answer the kid
is unreal you wish there were fans here even an
opposing building right now you watch something
remarkable like that Trevor zis Sports Center
Line one as he's done it again Fowler floats it
towards the net redirected in front by Terry Lela
moves over and they score on the lacrosse move
seis from behind the net and all Milano has to
do is get the heck out of the way what a play he
throws it in the net he doesn't stuff it this is
just unbelievable he goes around the right hip
of Sunny Milano and slams it jackets get it back
h Johnson Lee unable to get a stick on it look
at that it is the Michigan Ken Johnson circles
the n and then sends it home it's 3o Columbus
unbelievable and he doesn't do the wrap around
he goes for the Michigan something this kid does
all the time in practice and that's his first
Michigan in the National Hockey League stuffs it
top shelf highlight real goal here to the stick
side of Bennington Kev plays the rebound for badar
down low Bard the cross style scores unbelievable
Conor Bard oh my goodness on the back head holy
jumping he scooped that up like a acros player
reversed it in as a right hand shot and tucked
it by the glove of the goal tender bton oh my and
drops it off to zis Trevor takes it in behind the
that he scores a lacrosse goal wow you know the
thing about zis when he does this and executes
it is he's moving I've seen a lot of guys try
it but not while they're skating it almost full
speed what a Play What a Beautiful play by Trevor
Zas